stratégie
[Musique]
s il y avait 35 enfants de 2 à 14 ans il
y avait des vieillards des personnes
loin d'être en bonne santé de nos voeux
non monsieur certains étaient portés en
civière d'autres sur un cheval donné par
le début les gens étaient dénudés afin
d'avoir une marche et la nuit on
marchait 30 40 km pendant la nuit
parfois peut-être plus non le danger
était énorme
nous avons plusieurs fois été attaquée
par les allemands
soudain on a entendu des coups de feu
des tirs dans notre direction tout le
monde s'est dispersé
c'est assez ballet et là tout à coup
j'ai vu qu'il n'y avait personne près de
moi et a nié je ne savais pas quoi faire
courir un vrai chien s'est heureusement
ma soeur m'a vu je ne sais pas comment
elle m'a pris par la main et nous nous
sommes mis à courir
il s'est avéré que bas loin de l'endroit
où nous étions de la route forestière
il y avait des allemands bellinien ils
ont entendu des coups ils ont ouvert le
feu sans savoir ce qui se passe
mesdames beaucoup de personnes attablées
c'est gai et bouira nous ferait un
groupe d'allemands de lituaniens est
venu les toges et ce qu'on appelle la
première action a commencé dès le matin
pendant la journée jusqu'au soir à nice
ils ont cherché des juifs dans les
maisons il envoyait dans les rues ils
les abattent et comme des ânes un gros
échec
effacer la deuxième action a duré trois
jours
[Musique]
section dans un fossé s'était enfin
c'est très profond où il coulait nous
étions assis dans l'eau comme ça
ces trois jours nous entendions des gens
courir boom 20 tirs aïe
quelqu'un qui tombe à agnac ils ont
ouvert le fossé de nos voisins ayant
lancé une grenade
il y avait de tels hurlements des cris
des cris je m'en souviens non via une
jeune fille a eu les jambes arrachées
[Musique]
nous avions avec nous une petite fille
elle avait peut-être trois ans et à la
elle pleurait tout le temps quand nous
passions près de la rivière c'était un
endroit dangereux a pas à pas ce même et
est avait des allemands aux alentours
blu ray et tout le monde a commencé à
dire nous allons tous mourir à cause
d'elle il faut la noyée et on a donc
appris et on va les le père a dit à sa
femme
vas-y toile c'est le don du fel toi même
je ne peux pas et toi non plus c'était
qui c'est l'offre aux marquis celio fins
utiles voulait noyer la fille
rakia tenta piquette audio vo du coup on
va la chose
il s'est approché l'a prise dans ses
bras et l'a consolé je ne sais pas
comment les hawks qui en fait il l'a
porté pendant plusieurs semaines dans
ses bras au lieu de ses parents
bruit au lieu de ses parents
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]